just having having heard a bit of satan
tonight and having read a bit of macbeth
that there's a thing when you play a
baddie in shakespeare where you can be
sympathetic you can be you know we have
patrick stewart playing a sympathetic
child murderer in the West End on the
same day that we fill our front pages of
our tabloids with terrible things about
child murder it's a very odd coexistence
but you you have to leap the tragedy
train at some point as an audience as it
careers towards that the bloody buffers
you have to lose sympathy for him
however much he carries you along
because he's going to be damned that
doesn't happen with Satan because he's
not human
what's the worst thing that can happen
to him it's already happened and so
Milton it struck me tonight has done a
sort of extraordinarily extraordinary
Highjump imaginatively and morally he's
he's given you this person who you know
has all the best students and given you
sympathy for the devil which is also a
great team and then he sort of made it
impossible for you to withdraw your
sympathy from him because he's so
clearly having a worse time than you are
and and I'm not sure Shakespeare ever
quite does that and I just wanted to say
that I think it's um
it gives you quite a sort of vertigo
morally and that's yeah
you